very low pay very harsh working
conditions existed for farm workers
across the board one of the largest
products however coming out of
California was the grapes so strikers
were making this movement for justice
fair wages and safe working conditions
for me the importance is that the
Filipinos workers are the ones who began
the strike from Delano and I I was yeah
I have seven brothers and sisters and
five of us were born in labor camp so we
worked in the fields you know we our
home was surrounded by grapes
boycotting grapes affected global
markets because California supplies so
much of the global markets fruits and
vegetables so organizing with the grapes
first right and against particularly
well-organized growers and the
corporations that bought grapes from
these growers was an extremely important
stride not just for farm workers but for
labor in general
it was about two weeks after the strike
began that you know the feel of luring
the Filipino leaders knew that they
couldn't win the strike by themselves so
at that point they had gone to Caesar
and asked Caesar to join them and that
was the beginning you know of the two
units coming together I mean they were
risking their livelihood they were
risking their homes
you know while they lived in labor camps
I don't know if you would call those
homes but they're risking having a place
to live they didn't have families that
they could fall back lot to take care of
them they were risking a lot
when I was a little boy and I got it